[Music]
josh is with us in youngstown ohio hi
josh how are you
hi dave doing great thank you for uh
doing the service well thank you how can
i help
uh so my girlfriend turned me on to you
a couple weeks ago
and this thought has been in my head
ever since
i understand your love of credit cards
in our lives right
my question is if a person has the
discipline to live within their means
not overspend and stay within their
budget would it be
permissible so to speak in your system
to use a credit card if it can
accumulate you money
like i have one credit card that i've
ever had that gives me five percent cash
back on certain things at certain times
and
not only can i use that money to
accumulate for
future purposes so to speak as credit
that i don't have to pay towards
but i can also put that money straight
into my account and tax free if i choose
again i think the main word is
discipline but me personally i have no
debt
and i've used this to my advantage many
times but i was wondering how you felt
about it
yeah how old are you 30
31 31 okay when we did chris hogan's
book
the everyday millionaire we studied the
did the largest study
of millionaires in north america ever
done
over 10 000 of them and so we have
really good
data on what makes someone wealthy
out of the 10 167 millionaires that we
interviewed
not a single one said dave i made all my
money
with my credit card points
i took advantage of a multi-billion
dollar corporation
who has more invested in studying me
and my behavior patterns and i whipped
their butt
none of them said that none of them said
i'm going to join up for their game and
play it
and think i'm going to win none of them
said that
and so i consequently when i started
talking to wealthy people when i went
broke i was 28 years old when i went
broke i'm 60 now
i lost everything because of debt it
wasn't credit card debt but it was
because of that
and i started studying this stuff and
when i started studying wealthy people
i have never found anyone that thought
that was under the illusion
that they're actually winning at the
credit card game so i got out of the
credit card business i carry a debit
card and by the way the debit card will
do everything the credit card will do
except to accumulate these points
which we have established in the last
few moments are not a wealth building
method yes technically i do have a
debit card with my bank but i rarely use
this yeah um
that's what i have and that's all i have
and i just decided not to play their
game
okay because they let me tell you how
complicated and
sophisticated these guys are when you
call
citibank your zip code
shows up your nsx on your phone number
shows up and it dials in a zip code
meaning the first three digits of your
seven digit zip code and it pre
selects a script based on the area of
the country
that you're in and it pre-selects the
person who's going to be
speaking to you and what accent they're
going to have
and so if you're calling from the south
you're very likely if you're calling
customer service
to get someone from the south if you're
calling into collections
you're going to get someone from
brooklyn because
that's like fingernails down a
chalkboard for someone from the south
and their goal is to irritate you if
you're in collections
it's very sophisticated
they know the type of bottled water you
likely drink
before they pick up the phone they know
your buying patterns
they know your income levels based on
the zip code that you're in in your nsx
the data that they're operating with is
highly sophisticated
the chances of these guys losing money
on a transaction with you
is almost zero and so this is like
playing with a
very large old snake
that knows his stuff he's gonna bite
your freaking head off
so i wouldn't do it you do what you want
to do but i wouldn't do it
and um i've got friends that do it they
pay off their credit card every month
and
some of them are wealthy but none of
them are under the illusion that their
points
or their airline miles caused them to be
wealthy
nor are they under the illusion that
they're actually winning at a game
with freaking citibank or a game
with jp morgan or a game with i mean
can you imagine oh no no so i wouldn't
play with it sir
you asked my opinion and i think you
already knew it before you asked but
that's what i wouldn't do how long has
been since you had a credit card
uh when we first when stacy came to work
for you we cut our
we only had one that's 20 years ago yeah
uh yeah
you don't even know the difference i
mean it's again like you say the debit
card can do everything
it's real purchasing versus this myth
and you can just fall into a trap you
just never know
when some emergency happens if you don't
have the baby steps in place and you
don't have a real emergency fund in
place josh
uh you know you
you just it's it's too much of a
temptation
to then say oh well i've got it i'm
gonna use it now you're
now you're behind on the other the other
pieces of data we've got is
that they any kind of non-cash
transaction debit credit of apple pay oh
yes that's right any of these
what are called low friction
transactions when you spend with cash it
activates the pain centers of your brain
and it doesn't when you do a low
friction transaction with plastic and
actually credit cards are lower friction
because somewhere deep down in your
psyche you know you don't have to pay it
you don't have to have the money in the
account today
i just got to get my paycheck by the end
of the month or i can pay one of those
easy
payments right and somewhere down in
your psyche your your intellect tells
you that
and so you have a tendency to spend more
and all kinds of different pieces of
research showing that you spend more
with credit cards than you do with debit
cards and more with debit cards than you
do with cash
yeah that's just again because you it's
a psychology of behavior and it doesn't
matter how disciplined you are
i'm disciplined i teach this stuff for a
living and we're on a cruise ship and of
course they can there's no money on
cruise ship these days back when we used
to have cruises remember though
and uh your door key your door key will
buy anything on the boat
and i find myself buying the kids you
know six dollar ice cream cones or
whatever
same thing with disney property your
door key will work it's your it's your
own property and you can buy
you can buy one of those 63 raincoats
and not think anything about it because
it rains every afternoon doesn't he
arrange that true
and so um you know but you just don't
you don't
realize it emotionally that you're
overspending and that you're spending
more than you would even if you're
disciplined i'm pretty dead gum
discipline i teach this for a living
right
but i get back to the room and i'm like
one dad gum and you could afford a lot
of 63
bought some stuff i can afford it but
i'm just looking at the bill going we
bought some stuff you know it's like
swipe swipe swipe right
and um you know i heard you say this
once
we were talking about this one time we
have a mutual friend who posed that one
time we were hanging out at his house
and he was
literally asking all this and you said
the same thing
and it's funny that really wealthy
people don't need airplane miles
they don't like real wealth do they have
money
yeah they don't have their own plane
they don't care about the miles because
they go hey i think i want to go here
tomorrow
oh yeah i'm really rich i can do that